It's been a long day,
as you're probably gonna be able to tell.
I'm so tired.
But I have the hardest time sleeping
ever since I've been pregnant.
I don't know what it is.
So I asked my midwife,
and she told me to make this tart cherry
magnesium mocktail.
And I've also seen it all over TikTok.
I've actually been drinking it,
and I feel like it's been helping.
And Lucky's back,
so I'm gonna make both of us one tonight.
He's never had one, so.
Okay. So I usually start with my magnesium.
I do one scoop.
I'm gonna do one scoop here,
one scoop there.
Then I put some tart cherry juice in,
about this much. I give that a really good mix.
You stop it over there.
Cannot open bottles. Try it. I will try it.
See? You're having trouble, too. No.
Okay, well, that was quick.
Thanks, honey.
Put some ice in it.
I don't like that much ice.
I'm tired. Then I just top it with some sparkling water.
Sometimes I do a soda,
but today we're just gonna do this. There we go.
I'm gonna report back in the morning
and see whether he actually slept better.
How do you sleep